[Musique]
on a encore fait des progrès
techniquement en l'aide en accrochage
pour que la consommation des
Champs-Élysées se soit celle d'un
appartement de deux personnes de 50
mètres carrés sur 4 km 400 arbres seront
illuminés 400 âges illuminés avec des
LED 400 armes sont illuminés avec des
leds qui changeont de couleur il y aura
à la fois les étoiles de la Tour Eiffel
il y aura le doré du champagne et de la
fête à Paris c'est donc des éliminations
qui seront économes qui seront
brillantes qui seront joyeuses et qui
seront universelles donnés pour tout le
monde de la Concorde à l'Arc de Triomphe
[Musique]
mais c'est un travail en collaboration
avec les maires qui sont préoccupés et
comme on est partenaire de ces mairies
on essaie de trouver des solutions
ensemble pour préserver la magie de Noël
et en même temps faire des économies et
être responsables il y a un Tassin
ralentissement des commandes sur le mois
de septembre
au mois d'octobre ça repart un peu parce
qu'il y avait il y a eu il y a une
période un peu d'attente un peu de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on allait faire à
quelle sauce on allait être mangé là ça
repart un peu parce que parce que les
maires veulent l'illuminer alors
certainement si on compare par rapport
aux années précédentes sur un impact
[Musique]